hi I'm Jeff Bryant I'm - Nicola I'm the
manager of quality analysis at Wolfram
research and I'm a research program our
Wolfram research and we're going to be
giving a talk about the champagne 2017
marathon we're going to talk about the
sponsorship that Wolfram researched it
for the local Illinois Marathon I'm
going to give some background of the
whole story and then Jeff is gonna dive
into the more technical aspects and all
the coding that had to go into this
project so running at Wolfram I love to
run I do it a lot it's the only thing
I've ever really loved to do and there
are quite a few people here at the
company who who do it as well so many of
us like to run you can find us
everywhere all the time out on the roads
especially the champagne crowd is fairly
robust and not only do we have a
complete lack of you know entertaining
scenery but we also fight the elements
all the time whatever the weather it's
not good so whatever it is there's too
much of it we have too much Sun snow
humidity you name it we fight it so we
give kudos you can find us on RunKeeper
Strava we have a wolfram running group
there and an internal mailing list as
well at the company where we exchange
information so if you find your picture
here you have something to do with
running I found you somewhere in this
orbit so why do I like to run health of
course always a good reason but when I
go out on the street I'm really not
concerned about my expiration date and
considering how often you almost get hit
by a car it really seems
counterproductive it does help me
maintain some level of sanity or the
appearance there off it's location
independent I love it if I go travel I
pack an extra pair of running shoes out
the door you go it's amazing and my
favorite reason runners are really
friendly bunch of people when
you're out people greet each other they
chat they have stories you can hate on
the weather together it's great and if
you have ever participated in the race
you will see the spectator signs there
to die for they're really hilarious
often politically incorrect and are read
it so there are a few examples these are
not necessarily from Champaign but you
see them you know and all the cities are
alike there is some pretty good ones so
to give some background as I said I've
always run but I didn't get into longer
distances until 2014 I have done eight
marathon since then and one of them was
the Bank of America Chicago Marathon in
2015 I really liked it I you know after
I got done I come back to work we sit
down and talk about the event and the
fact that close to 40,000 participants
were at this event which makes for a
fabulous dataset there's nothing we like
more at ed wolfram than a big yes that
we can play around with
so we napped the data we turned it into
an entity store and then in 2016 I wrote
a blog post about my experience in
Chicago and so we don't didn't just look
at an individual runner it's really the
the field of runners where everyone
comes from what does the group of the
four-hour runners look like which people
ran together or you know if you travel
thousands of miles you have this giant
expenditure on a marathon do you come
from a country that has a high GDP does
this relate you have deep pockets all of
those assumptions were incorrect by the
way so after we published the blog post
we then took up a conversation with the
local race administration and they
really liked the idea here in Champaign
to work with us they really liked having
a software company as a sponsor and if
you consider it's not a big event it's
not Boston it's not New York you know
they always look for something that sets
them apart
from other big races and so they were
all for it
so why is the sponsorship good for us
well it is a really good event to be
part of it ties together both
communities the little spikey shows our
location edible from research and the
runners like for the marathon you start
outside State Farm Center and on your
way you cross campus you go through both
downtown areas all major like a lot of
residential neighborhoods Park features
really anything that's relevant in this
town and the kicker of course is that
you get to finish inside Memorial
Stadium which is just amazing it's it's
a really nice thing to go through you
know you you come in you have the
speakers you have the music you have two
crowds in the in the stands and it's
it's really amazing the event itself has
become quite relevant for the community
so was first held in 2009 the number of
runners since then has doubled basically
it was it started with five events on
just one day it has grown into nine
events over two days it's a Friday night
and a Saturday we have a lot more
volunteers many more sponsors hotel
partners and the economic impact is you
know it's quite a bit this is all you
know the runners coming in and solidly
booking all available hotel rooms for
the weekend
spending money locally you know going
out and also the charitable giving has
reached a million dollars so this year
alone I think it was $130,000 which is
just it's a really good event to be part
of so then we have some random numbers
and Wolfram Alpha has something to tell
you for all of them which is great so
taking the nine events from 2017 we
covered one hundred ninety eight
thousand twenty five miles which is
comparable to 0.8 three times the mean
moon Earth distance or three million
soccer fields
food.we oh not yet so marathon literally
would not happen had Walter hunt not
invented the safety pin back in 18-49 so
we need 80,000 of them for one such
marathon now the food runners gobbled
through 1600 oranges 15,000 bananas 9600
gallons of water and almost 2,000
gallons of butyrate and that's just
along the racecourse there's sugar in
those oranges 20 kilograms is staggering
but I will tell you an orange size at
Mile 20 when you start to question your
life choices will fix everything and
also WolframAlpha can tell you that we
can fill two bathtubs with those oranges
so then it is just obscene then at the
finish line
we need another 800 pounds of pasta 1100
pizza and go through 30 almost 33,000
bottles of water the calorie count in a
pasta and pizza is 1.8 million which
again quite staggering but that's not
where it stopped this year the theme of
the marathon was a hundred and fiftieth
birthday of the U of I so naturally the
race administration decides to order 70
sheet cakes by the dimensions of
eighteen times 24 inches so we call them
io bakery to find out that one of those
cakes has more than 25,000 21,000
calories which makes another one and a
half million which then again is
actually comparable to the 15,000
bananas I mentioned before which makes
for an interesting conversation with
your child if you take the you know base
sheet cake unit off two by two inches
whether to sheet cake or to banana also
WolframAlpha can tell you that the sheet
cakes make up 150 times the calories
that Michael Phelps takes injuring his
Olympic training days or it
you know two years of food intake
foresting a person so what to do with
those calories
now you've run the marathon WolframAlpha
can tell you with those default values
of you know your meal clothes 160 pounds
you run the marathon distance at a
nine-minute my pace you burn a little
over 3000 calories which it'll take
about 500 marathons to burn off just the
sheet cake calories but guilt-free after
marathon you get a free beer so if we
take this into account just to replenish
the calories you burn through a marathon
you could if you were capable have 28 of
those free beers or back to the sheet
cakes 15 of those pieces
did I mention weather so weather is
crucial in champagne it's just not a
very forgiving place to run here and
it's it's always a problem for the race
administration so if we just look at
2016 and use some weather data the rain
basically waited for the event to happen
it moved in it Unleashed and it just
stayed for the length of the marathon so
by the time I cross the starting line I
was drenched there was not a dry minute
through this entire event and if you
look we start at 7:00 a.m. and people
are on the course for six seven seven
and a half hours and they got all of it
interestingly this is not the low point
for champagne the low point for
champagne is 2015 when we get a
thunderstorm and not even as marinas
2016 but the thunderstorm created so
much lightning that was really close to
the racecourse and we had a lot of
lightning hit the ground in too close
proximity that during the race at some
point the administration had to cancel
mid race this doesn't happen often
marathons do get canceled but not mid
race while you have thousands of people
on the course so that was an administer
a nightmare I will admit I was at Mile
18 the cops come by they tell us it's
kids oh my god I had the worst race I
had the horse race and I was not one of
the people that just was dedicated
enough to finish I bail it's like I was
gone but I did keep the noose cadet from
that weekend because it was really it
was just such a horrible weekend but but
yes so that's the background and so now
over the summer 2017 we got the data set
from the 2017 race from Champaign and
I'm gonna hand over to Jeff he's gonna
talk about that
okay everyone hear me okay all right so
I am NOT a marathon runner but I got to
stay behind and process data
it's a Herculean task in its own right
real-world data is extremely messy I
don't know how many of you out there
actually have ever tried to actually
clean up some kind of a CSV file
anything like that in the real world and
tried to make it computable I know
pretty much everybody in WolframAlpha
knows all about this because we do that
a lot but there's a number of tools that
are very useful for cleaning this up
Stephen actually had a blog a little
while back and I'll have there's a link
to that in the talk here where he has
kind of a 10-step process for how to
clean data to make it computable and
that's good good good tips to follow by
so the first thing we did was we had to
import the CSV file and you can see here
the from the header the CSV file some of
the properties that are provided in the
data set that they give us we've also
looked at other marathons not just
Champaign but we've looked at a/c
Philadelphia Pittsburgh we've done
Houston we've kind of done these as
background things and they all pretty
much have basically the same properties
we have to tweak things a little bit on
a per race basis but one thing in common
is that they're all very messy you have
to do a lot of cleanup to make the data
computable one of the best tools that
you need to use is interpreter the data
comes in as a string but if you want to
compute with it strings are kind of hard
to compute with but the Wolfram language
has a lot of entities in them
you want to convert a lot of these
things into entities things like this
city where the runner came from their
zip codes their gender these are all
things that the Wolfram language has a
representation of as an entity and so
how do you turn these strings into one
of these entities and figure out what it
is once you've done that you can
actually get access to things properties
and city data
you know the actual latitude longitude
of those cities things that you can
actually compute with but you've got to
align them first and that's where
interpreter comes in scroll down a
little here so here's an example where
from the CSV file we're able to get
their city their state in the country
put those together and string join them
and then you can call interpreter city
on it and what you get back is the
entity representation so each one of
these calls essentially goes through a
Wolfram Alpha parser and then turns it
into the internal representation now the
problem is this can be messy as I
mentioned before is all data can be
here's an example of something that
might fail so you always have to have
fallback plans there's never just that
this will always work for you usually
have to make multiple passes to clean
things up so here's a case where
somebody put in for their city Scott Air
Force Base it's not really a city we've
seen all kinds of weird things
especially in the city fields people
will put in their address they don't
actually put the city they put an
address in they put an Air Force Base
they put a neighborhood that's a subtle
differentiation they might say Queens
rather than New York but from a an
alignment point of view it's actually
it's a difference so these can all throw
off an attempt to align these things so
often what we were able to do here was
we were able to fall back to their zip
code in the event we couldn't figure out
what city they were from and postal code
is provided so you're able to do that
and then we can call geo nearest on the
resulting city to determine what they
are and it turns out we actually did
have Scott Air Force Base right there
and we were actually getting able to get
the alignment sometimes these
misalignments because the thing they
provided aren't a city sometimes it's
because they misspelled it sometimes
it's because we're lacking when
linguistics and so the
or sometimes cues for us to add
linguistics to our stuff to pick some of
these up but there are all things that
you're trying to clean up the day be
you've got to be prepared for that's it
okay one of the biggest things most of
the data that you really get out there
that you really care about are the the
split times so the champagne marathon
had several different splits of course
there's the start then there's the 10k
the 10-mile the half the 20-mile and the
finish some of the other marathons
actually have more splits than that
champagne just has a little fewer it's a
smaller scale marathon so but they
provide the split times as strings just
like everything else in the CSV file and
we want to turn these into quantities so
that we can compute with them and you
have to be very careful so for example
here is an example where we take the
string value we do a string split on it
to get rid of the colon we convert those
into numbers using from digits and then
we turn that into a quantity that's
mixed magic magnitude hours minutes
seconds looks like we're all done
not quite you have to be very careful
because the data set actually contains
not just the full marathon runners but
it also contains people that ran say the
5k and the problem is that the
difference between those runners is how
they report at the Times sometimes they
gave you a string that looks like this
notice the first numbers 25 there now if
we always assumed that this was hours
minutes seconds that would be a really
slow runner so something was obviously
wrong and it turns out it's because they
had actually done for the 5k people they
had done minutes seconds milliseconds so
we had to actually put some logic in our
thing as to how to what units were
supposed to use here and at first we
thought we were done we looked back it's
like wow this is really weird results
and it turns out it's because of this
issue once again real world data is very
messy then for assembling the data as I
mentioned before we actually used an
entity store how many has anybody here
actually used an entity store actually
tried creating one they're fairly new I
think they've was a version 10 we added
them yeah so they're new as of version
10 they're essentially the user way of
creating your own data packet so if you
guys are familiar with the data
we had since version six and then
starting in version 10 we had entity
value we have our own those are still
kind of data packets just accessible
through the entity value framework you
can now create your own and the way you
do that is essentially you set up it's
essentially like a list of rules but
it's done an association form and you
basically have your property labels
followed by their values and once you've
got all these set up this is an example
I guess you could say an entity and all
of its properties for the marathon and
you can see we've already aligned this
some of these things just stay two
strings like the last name of a person
you know there's not much you can do
there there's not going to be an entity
for every last name possible but first
names Walter things like that but other
things like the city we can align those
with entities the state you can align
those with entities country zip codes
we've got the gender in there we were
able to align with an entity a lot of
these things are just numerical data so
you leave those over please leave those
as they are but then you get down to the
splits and you can see for each one we
were able to construct the net time as a
quantity the time of day and then the
pace now the pace doesn't really make
sense until you get down to the first
split after the start but then you start
getting how many minutes per mile the
person ran so once you do that for all
of the the rows in the CSV file before I
talk about how to assemble those we
actually had two sets within our entity
store one was the list of runners and
the other was the list of divisions so
you have various divisions within the
data set where you had
here's a list of all the ones that the
Champaign Marathon included for example
male 22 24 this is their age ranges so
typically the divisions were broken up
by by sexes and then also by by age with
a few others down there at the end and
then for each division you had different
properties like the mean that time
things like that and then the list of
properties for a given division you can
see right there lets you all speed up
here a little bit I'm running out of
time and then the last step after you
get those as you actually assemble the
entity store and that's basically just a
wrapper with metadata
you basically take those lists those
associations and those would go in these
positions right here where you say
here's the entities you specify what the
properties are and they're and the
labels the yellow boxes that show up
those are the labels and that's it when
you're done you just write it out and
you've got an empty to store you're
ready to register it and you're ready to
compute with it and then this is this is
a link from Stephens talk actually this
is his ten step process for cleaning up
data he's got a whole blog entry on this
that he's quite proud of but it's a very
nice chart here that kind of shows if
you can get like I think he mentioned
you can get to five you're in pretty
good shape but you can go all the way
down to ten and just have really nice
computable data so I'll let you guys
read through that on your own time I
think we've got a few more things we
want to show here before the end so I
think that's my last slide I think it's
verify yep okay so I'm gonna switch back
to ila I so the question now is what did
we actually produce for Champaign for
2017
it hasn't launched yet it's work in
progress um design is still gonna work
some magic on it but I can show you a
couple things and let's go here first so
we you at the very top so what we did is
we're generating a movie there's the
winners you can see them down here male
and female winner
median and the center of gravity are pre
generated you can then specify a bib
number your bib number or you know if
you want to compare yourself to other
people and we will add a dot for you in
this movie and so that's you and it
starts running so the purple wave shows
that how the field of runners is you
know passing along the racecourse the
height of each purple bar indicates you
know and a certain number of runners per
I think the base was half a kilometre
and it's nice because you can see the in
the beginning were all very concentrated
there's a wave start but you know
everyone's on the course within I think
30 minutes but then you know the first
runners are off the field incredibly
fast the last runners they take you know
as I said the first runners are like two
hours and some minutes the latest
runners is I think
they take up seven and a half hours so
the curve flattens out because we're
stretching along the course and I've I
always said like this is you know if
you're traveling spectator this is a
really good way for you to for you to
watch and decide where am I going to put
my folding chair you know when are the
masses coming by my neighborhood and so
what we did in addition to this movie
because we've had something similar for
the blog posts we can now tell you for
so Nicole Anderson I made sure not to
have a wolfram Runner as an example here
so we tell you your placement which is
something you get from the regular race
results anyway but we can tell you there
were two people with the same first name
you were the fastest if you were there
were six people with the same last name
Anderson and you were faster than three
of them this lady we can also tell her
that she just barely missed her Boston
qualifier by one minute and 35 seconds
so you know less than two minutes over
the course of a race and that's gonna
hurt a little bit and then we can tell
you for you know the field of all
runners the the red part of the pie is
who people that did not qualify we're
not within a 30-minute range the yellow
is how many were within 30 minutes
because I think if you're within 30
minutes of a Boston qualifier you might
want to plan and maybe adjust your
training if this is on your to-do list
the green is all the people that did
qualify and then the same for your for
the division so that's the people that
really you should be comparing yourself
to we give a histogram again for the
different splits and the red indicates
where you are so this is you know when
all the people pass through those splits
this lady did pretty well so and then
this is also the performance over the
course of the race and that means at
what percent or at what percentage of
the field was she at those given splits
so she she got a little so she was
always you know within the 80% range of
which means we so 100 percent is fast
so she did really really well and then
at the very end is a heat map so for you
know where did all the runners come from
and the very last thing that I have to
show so of course we took 2017 we took
the attendee list and ran it against the
employee directory and to make sure we
get everyone who ran the marathon and
there were four of us
and I would say I'm the slowest but he
is the movie so Rebecca Leary yay and
I'm in there
Rebecca's killing it yay and Larry
should clearly be training together
because you were in the same spot for
basically the entire race and I'm just
trailing so but that's it thank you
[Applause]